hello and welcome back to new rockstars
i'm jessica clements and i'm here to
break down one of my favorite comic book
to tv show adaptations the boys season
three and what season four might have in
store with the vp running mate victoria
newman red river institute black noir
being dead and homelanders new single
dad lifestyle while we hosted the boys
underground after show breaking it down
weekly here i'm just gonna give you a
super quick more in-depth knowledge of
who we may have forgotten about and what
new characters and stories could arrive
in season four yes season four has
already been in the works they start
shooting in late august according to an
interview from variety with the boys
showrunner eric kripke so season four
could be right around the corner i think
this goes without saying but i'm about
to spoil so just heads up season three
follows our regular band of misfits
still trying to take out homelander they
team up with soulja boy our captain
america-esque superhero from back in the
day who we later find out is homelanders
biological father and just insanely
gross homelander is an emotional
rollercoaster from the beginning to end
continuing to be the best villain i've
ever seen he kills the newest
seven-member supersonic innocent
bystanders not so innocent termite and
black noir but with this sort of
downward spiral comes civilian support
when homelander decides to finally open
up on live tv in his numbers shoot up
baby victoria newman aka lady head
popper aka by who by me started the show
as the director of federal bureau of
superhuman affairs ends the season as
bob singer's us vp running mate and it
is revealed to be stan edgar's daughter
are you seeing a theme here ashley is
basically standing chief executive while
stan edgar is dethroned by homelander
and his own daughter maeve while helping
butcher is caught by homelander
imprisoned and vaught later to fight
homelander and soldier boy but don't
worry her story ends happily a train has
a new heart but ruins his relationship
with his brother the deep who you
thought couldn't get worse in fact gets
way worse mother's milk starts to dive
into his ocd and continues to be the
best dad on the show yes so is huey's
dad but he's in this season for like a
minute tops kamiko loses her powers and
gains for them back and learns some sick
dance moves along the way with frenchie
this season was a lot it was very
gruesome a very emotional but we all
knew the theme was fathers feels good
feels right it was father's father's
father's the biggest reveal this season
was in episode 7 where we find out
soulja boy is homelanders biological dad
which immediately had us all wondering
okay who is the mom our amazing
cameraman dash all during the boys
underground pitch stormfront which
though disgusting factually sound
homelander was born sometime in spring
1981 using the semen of soldier boy and
an unknown egg donor if stormfront had
knowingly decided to use her own eggs
she definitely picked out soulja boy and
a list of soups according to soulja boy
in episode 6 and 52 he and stormfront
founded herogasm so they met way before
1980 when vogelbaum asked him for a
sample and there's also the super weird
hierarchy too because stan edgar was
emailing stormfront about the successful
trials at sage grove so stormfront still
had a lot of sway and free choice in
making decisions which of course she did
she's the wife to dr vaught and if she
unknowingly gave her eggs it could have
been in 1939 when dr vaught of vaughn
internationals was testing compound v on
her because remember she's the first
successful suit and with advanced
freezing methods you can freeze your
eggs for a very long time and before you
say jessica but she loves homelanders so
much why wasn't she there for him when
he was a baby
in 1979 stormfront disappeared no one
heard from her again but i'm sure her
goals in creating a nazi army surpassed
that of being a mother so she might have
been there as sage grove in hiding for
vote watching her son grow into a man
disgusting another huge impact of the
show is ryan now and a loving embrace of
homelander his daddy this father-son
relationship is toxic there i said it
but we should remember there's a ton of
resources for homelanders more so ryan
with invite we're already ramping up for
the boy spin-off series where young
soups are tested in a hunger game style
challenges at the golduckin i know i'm
pronouncing that name wrong when you
read comic books your entire life and
then you have to say them out loud you
realize you're saying every name wrong
that's a made up word what was it made
of
university school of crime fighting
clearly founded by john godolcon godokin
godokin
who like an evil charles xavier has his
own horrible past in the comics that
will save for the spin-off breakdown but
we know that jasmine sinclair is cast it
as marie moreau who we briefly see in
episode 2 as one of the several soups at
the red river institute there's also
teenage kicks and the young americans
the adolescent super teams we haven't
really seen yet the teenage kicks were
the troublemakers the young americans
were the old-fashioned nicest pie types
if it sounds familiar it's because the
young americans gave us super sonic and
starlight in the comics in the show it
was the capes for christ circuit if you
remember there's a ton of teams in the
comics including the midwest guardians
even tech night going on to say g nomads
the g brits g-whiz every single last one
of them either way we see ryan getting
stronger every day he's gonna need
guidance soon more guidance than
whatever homelander can give his
superpowers mimic that of homelanders
and ryan is super bright maybe
homelander tries to put him in the
spin-off clearly we'll be introduced to
more child and teen soups under vaught
in season 4 because of varsity and
varsity has some characters and themes
from season 3 that will go into season
4. but more importantly a child team
with ryan as the appointed leader seems
like something we're headed towards or
maybe just a super evil ryan a super
evil ryan team either way he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna need people oh my
baby black noir spent his last minutes
of season three building his courage to
face soulja boy just to get his organs
rearranged by homelander and not like
that now he's dead or is he black noir
can survive almost anything including
even having his head ripped open brains
three feet from his body but a punch
through the stomach kills him i am
buying it eric kripke said in an
interview black noir is dead his organs
are out all over the place but when you
have a completely silent completely
masked clad hero they're reasonably easy
to recast
yeah okay um actually in the comics we
know lamplighter along with blarney [ __ ]
and nubia all came back after death
resurrected by vot in no way is it
glamorous but i suspect when trying to
speed up his regenerative powers or
maybe just fix him quicker than normal
we're gonna turn my boy into a super
zombie so is he really alive if he's a
zombie of course not kripke but i will
probably cry if you do this to my boy
and let's not forget about little nina
the mob boss drug dealer she is still
free after torturing kamiko shari and
frenchie in episode six and the series
frenchie used to do jobs for nina back
in the day and when french's ex charity
crossed her and lost her supply nina
wanted her dead they settled on the
location of soulja boy for killing this
russian oligarch who got in her bad
books the guy that got
dildoed in the neck in the comics values
nina to re-crew a bunch of people turn
them into soups with this bogus compound
beat and stage a coup in actuality
they'd try and she would stop them dead
looking like the angel of moscow vaught
gave her a remote that would detonate
and explode all their heads but of
course it was the bum remote vaught was
setting her up the storyline is so fun
and victoria newman is so power hungry
could strike a deal with little nina she
already did with homelander she took out
her dad next bob singer from president
of the united states to russian ally i
mean come on it's written in the stars
we don't know if victoria newman will
kill the president but we do know in the
comics victor newman aka vic the veep
did kill the president and was later
killed by homelander so our storyline is
already following the comic book one
lastly we can hopefully see cindy the
telekinetic suit from season two at the
sage grove center in season four
showrunner eric kripke said cindy's out
there he then mentions reaching out to
the actress and her busy schedule so
they're figuring it out he closes with
cindy will return there's no way cindy
doesn't return cindy is too cool not to
return anyone who exits the show to the
golden girls intro is damn cool in my
book crafty so please bring her back we
need to remember that she can crush
people with their telekinetic powers
make them pop literally kind of like
what victoria newman can do with
people's heads so her and victoria
newman in a battle would be epic all
right that's just some of the things
i've spotted and theorized let me know
yours in the comments below follow me on
instagram at twitter lulu clemens follow
new rockstar subscribe hit that
notification bell thanks for watching
make sure to jump back to the boys
underground where myself marina and
fellow new rockstars chat the boys and
lada gatos have a nice night let's go
crazy
[Music]
you